[Music]
and why not use submitted by your
northern brothers Canadians yeah
Canadian Mort wait they're both right
gain signs and they both reach the
letter n Nikki North the world's biggest
election loser runs again for the 96th
time oh why you don't give up never give
up okay so he's lost 96 times yep
what is he running for it came in Canada
you know it's funny a lot of people
gonna hate me for this but like I was
studying Bernie Sanders and haha yeah I
mean he's a great speaker that I love
the [ __ ] that he says it's awesome
there's like roasted Bernie sander don't
think he lost a lot and I was like oh
wow well you can't win if you don't lose
oh I guess you can't you could win if
he's like 81 dizzy I don't know it looks
like it he looks like a solid 250 years
I appreciate the people that keep that
lose and lose and lose and keep trying
yeah it kind of gives me hope you know
makes me laugh but it also makes me
wonder like um why maybe they learned
each time they look lost Joe and then
now they're the people that actually
took that saying too harshly don't you
ever give up but if you learn each time
you lose then how come you can't you
never ever win after magna five times
Thomas Edison lost thousands of times
was it really I don't know how many
times it's about it you did lose a lot
longer time it's all about balance we do
it again okay real quick an election
season is a lot of time to go by right I
feel like what Thomas Jefferson did is
like he's like okay does this work
no does this work no like oh and now
that'll be another year long fair you
think Thomas Edison have it's so easy he
was just like no I don't I'm just saying
that the variance is to what he was
experimenting on you
and a shorter time period between their
own content improvement it's like okay I
got closer to this I got new demo each
time with an election why don't you [ __ ]
this guy Nicky holy [ __ ] I love him I'm
voting for you [ __ ] this 80 year old man
I think there's just gotta be some wins
though it's got to go up and down like
if you're constantly losing like let's
say you're a boxer and you're always
losing and it gets to the point where
you're that near that pass around box
you're that practice you're that
practice guy that like new guys come to
[ __ ] up
that's like Rocky these are like the
people that I know who have been
vlogging since YouTube began and they
get 18 views a video and they're still
at it yeah they're still doing it yeah
there are I know something for you by
the way good for you but it well you
know but they may be people that aren't
changing anything yeah of course they
are so I think it's okay to lose if you
change things and try because that's
like me like okay like for example I
accidentally walked into a hard sparring
session right and if I told myself that
you know what I'm doping imma keep going
there I would not have a face right now
yeah I wouldn't literally have no teeth
in my mouth you know but I walked in I
got my ass handed to me by like 14
people like all right this is not for me
maybe I need a you know get improving to
come back you know I'm not going there
doing the same [ __ ] over and over and
continually failing I get that so this
dude here his name is John Turmel the
first time you ran in an election was in
1979 and he was trying to legalize
gambling because he is an illegal
gambler and his Hogan was don't vote for
John to me he's like [ __ ] that didn't
work hey we'll try next year I can tell
he's a gambler [ __ ]
he's addicted to lose it is one of his
first run as a real life Ozark dude now
yes I go back what the photos they say
are equals percent entry solution or
equals zero it doesn't rhyme so trying
to make he meets the rim you got to have
something Ryan that's true click it or
ticket thank you there you go yeah so he
was trying to make I create social
credit so it was pretty much like having
people
their own currency and yeah it's like
people can create like they turned their
time into a currency that they wouldn't
use with other people that is called
dollars it's called early cryptocurrency
you were to get your money and then your
money buys things he's ahead of his time
that's the problem he says people with
no money can basically create their own
tokens by monetizing their own time what
he called it time thinks he has a really
complicated way of just describing work
yeah regular work just talkin yeah yeah
it's like an hour of my time equals X
amount of dollars
exactly I want to start something called
minimum wage so that's why he's losing
to people like Bo that exists
you're just rephrasing it have it sis
you know there's a system that exists it
doesn't it's like [ __ ] Vanessa like
my former assistant she would always
said she was I had this great idea and
it's already something that exists as is
now cuz she loves watching that one show
what's attracting shark tank right she
goes I got this idea right so doing your
[ __ ] stuck in your teeth you get a piece
of string and you wrap it up into a
little plastic it's called floss [ __ ]
the best thing about Shark Tank is
there's always something that nobody
needs it's like it's like okay you see
you talk about floss or like you got
something stuck in your teeth these guys
like okay you know how you get stuck in
your teeth you put this in your mouth
and now you got it in your mouth and
nothing you get stuck in your teeth and
you're like I don't nobody need no no I
mean it you know I like is the shower
drain thing that catches the hair I know
that is actually great that's the thing
I have to deal with now yes cuz I'm Mari
el nice it moved she moved in no she's
always shot on my [ __ ] place and
closet [ __ ] up in a matter of like two
days yeah yeah all it takes is two times
two days to do this I thought we were
getting a life update for a second I got
excited sorry about everything back to
normal everybody back to home back to
one moment things start progressing in
our relationship where we actually start
acting like a real couple that's been
together for years I'll let you guys
know we clean your house
I'm such a fool David I always think
today's a day and I never is yes
literally today yeah today that's my why
I proposed a barrel most good proposal
Steve do you have to be they give me
enough blue balls about it I deserve it
he's missed our trikes oh yeah well but
yeah this dude now he's just known as
The Biggest Loser but he doesn't even
care because he's like honestly I'm not
even he does it ought to do anything
else he's like [ __ ] is he making money
he's [ __ ] wealthy because your
campaign you're spending grip of money
dude that's what I'm saying
he's engine even engineered so he has a
day job and he gambled it all away on
politics he doesn't gamble now anymore
because he only uses his gambling money
to run his politic stuff but he says
like he doesn't even do that much it was
just like he signs up he'll show up
whenever there's a debate and that's
pretty much it he doesn't do any like
campaigning you think he loses a
gambling to [ __ ] hobby losing this is
what politicians do when they come to
speak like for a [ __ ] right and end oh
they'll come up and then do like kind of
network and then hear what the events
about and then they would all line up
and start doing their speeches but they
get all the intel on the day of just
like talking to people what is this
event about they don't know [ __ ] about
it dude they'll be like okay so this is
about this story and I'm like damn y'all
are great bullshitters dude me Nicky
were just hanging out the politician
we're at a wedding and then he was
running for City crown for City Council
what the [ __ ] is his name he's running
for City Council on Carson yeah and his
first name is Orlando I think or or more
Omar anyway vote for him if you live a
nice guy don't guys not Jim dear yeah
not Jim dear not Jimmy that guy [ __ ]
that guy but all you know he just kept
talking about him well we kept seeing
signs of Jim dear and then we heard you
were in for Gaza they were like oh what
about Jim dear oh well we're breaking
supposable hot Jimmy was gonna kill him
in the race because he's got signage
everywhere and he's like oh I know man
he's like this is breaking my [ __ ]
that was I hate Jim dear 9-3 but yeah
sorry then the signs are everywhere
hey all night the only people that vote
for local politics are senior citizens
yeah like my mom or she works or
politics but the rest of us just
complain about it yeah there's so much
related to a fast track claim there's so
much research involved in politics the
reason why I don't have an opinion about
politics cuz I don't know [ __ ] me too
amount of research is this big yeah and
statistics aren't even factual anymore
now they're so [ __ ] biased so I don't
know what the [ __ ] to think anymore you
get that big-ass booklet in the mail
every time there's an election telling
you and I'm just only people that
actually care about local politics or
seniors because they don't want a
[ __ ] speed bump there or they do want
to speed or whatever school
administration like teachers and that's
maybe more the only thing that you can
actually change something isn't this
what Obama got elected I was like ugh
sick
there's gonna be no more or this stupid
middle east to worship no and guess what
it all got ramped up we're into Libya
I'm like [ __ ] this [ __ ] no matter who
you vote for we went to more war machua
war forever
there's no it's all a big [ __ ] show
biggest business yeah it's all a show
that's what I that's true cuz that was
what Obama was campaigning on it he was
gonna pull all of us out of that Jam he
got out of Iraq even when we got out of
a rat we weren't out of Iraq you see
people get so invested in sides and they
like it's like they fight for this tribe
like as if that as if that politician
has their background I also just don't
think any politician has anyone's back
they have the back of their bar Orlando
that's my [ __ ] dude
no not good not a good whatever your
little placard thing you gave me wasn't
very good signage because I don't
remember but wait wait so you know
policy there whatever it is absolutely
not he was just a sick dude to hang with
and I think that he should win for it
really yeah I do
Omar Orlando yeah but that's great
whatever it is it wouldíve you she got a
mall more Orlando popper and if you live
in Carson Richard perks they end up guys
there's like three candidates laying
there going for the third one is ya know
most people will get in the voting booth
and they'll be like wait what oh yeah I
heard Jim dear a lot oh yeah yeah this
John dude that keeps losing in Canada he
said this I have no regrets for a guy
with no resources doing it all with my
winnings from my mainly illegal games to
be ashamed of you better both with this
guy now trying to like push for like
prostitution and legalizing drugs he
does all of them so for like since the
70s he's been [ __ ] hookers gambling
and he's been getting away with it
yeah cuz he was like well what other way
am I gonna get it legalized he's been
doing it anyway illegally yeah I totally
people yeah I like this guy at least
he's upfront and honest
I'm gonna vote for him yeah okay okay
Joe response hi we had a writers room of
people to come up with the perfect Joe
response to what was just said there we
could have spent eight hours and not
come up with that right you have to have
Joe to develop lines for Joe
[Music]
[Music]